one of the most frightening aspects of
working life is that we will unless we
are the beneficiaries of extreme good
fortune be required to have colleagues
the colleague is a creature who endured
over any length of time in situations of
high stress and procedural complexity
presents one of the greatest threats to
calm composure and soundness of mind it
was so much easier when we were kids we
could lie on the bedroom floor and in a
few minutes of play build a plane run a
restaurant or invade a country on our
own
the problem with collies starts with the
fact that they can't get what we want
everything needs to be explained to them
often very slowly and repeatedly if this
were not bad enough many colleagues are
at high risk of disagreeing with us
about many things they turn out to have
a host of contrary opinions their own
quirks pet peeves and obsessive interest
and yet worse they are very sensitive if
low and behold we have to manage them
unless we speak to them in the right way
they'll become offended develop grudges
start to cry or report one to a superior
in the good old days you could just
shout when most were considered
management could hear that emotional
distress didn't hold things up one could
still operate the brick making machine
at maximum speed even if one hated a
manager or clean out the stables
thoroughly even if one salesperson has
inquired deeply enough into the nature
of one's weekend but nowadays most jobs
require a high degree of psychological
well-being in order to be performed
adequately the wounding comment can
destroy a person's productivity for a
whole day without ample respect
recognition and encouragement huge sums
of money can get wasted in silent and
resentful mood if one has any concern
for the bottom line it seems one has a
little alternative but to try to be a
little bit like work relationships are
no little trickier than romantic ones
but at least in the latter
we have a basic sense of security that
enables one to speak one's mind make
necessary cathartic moves to call them
[ __ ] and compress a range of ideas
in the occasional expletive loaded felt
first the office environment misses out
on the cleansing frankness seemingly
possible only when two people know they
will have the options but having sex
together after the busting at the heart
of our office Agony's is a complaint
that we seldom like our colleagues at
people in a better world we would be
unlikely ever to want to spend any time
at all with such disturbing and often
unlikely figures we shouldn't be
surprised by our daily discomfort given
that these people were never picked out
on the basis of psychological
compatibility we were formed into a unit
because they had a range of technical
and commercial competences necessary for
a child not because their son lunch
containers or grapes with a pleasing
manner we are like the unfortunate bride
in a power marriage in the Middle Ages a
princess would be obliged to marry a
certain prince because he owned an
important led mine or the archers in his
country were especially proficient it
would have been nice if the two liked
each other a bit as well the subjects
were generally far too high for this to
be a relevant factor the success of the
realm depended on such matters as access
to raw materials and military strength
not on whether the partner had a
maddening giggle or a daunting over pile
to work well around colleagues requires
not talent per se but success at a range
of dark psychological are best summed up
by the word politics but political skill
has woefully little in common with the
reasons we were trained and hired to do
our jobs in the first place we may as
part of a good business education for
spent years studying the way to navigate
a balance sheet and life competitive
negotiate contracts with administer
logistics hang could life at work
require quite different skills the
capacity to quietly accept glory for
things that were not truly are doing to
distance ourselves from errors in which
we were heavily implicated to subtly
foreground the failings of otherwise
quite able colleagues
turn called a key moment toward
emotionally vulnerable superior to
flattered while not appearing to do so
to mold our view to suit the currently
ascendant attitudes our inevitable
difficulties are aggravated by notions
that offices are at hard really giant
families that colleagues can be friends
that honesty is rewarded and that talent
will win out kindly sentimentality is in
the end just a disguised version of
cruelty it might be a lot simpler if in
dark moments we could simply admit to
what we know in our hearts that it would
obviously be a great deal better we
could be shot of the whole business of
colleagues and could instead spend our
days that we used to do so well on our
own
you